oh embiid used the shoulder into the  face of harold now harrell almost  tackles him and watch out  joel embiid put his hands it looked like  around the neck of mantras harold they  will definitely take a look at this  this is these are the moments right here  at jk i want to go get a jersey  [Music]  nyang has a couple of threes  embiid goes to the offensive glass he  draws the foul  and a push here by harrell and  that's going to be number two against  montres  he's gone  joel i mean he just knows  how to get under guy skin  jd rawls is the one who made the call on  the technical  he has ejected montrez harrell there is  a shove by harrell against embiid  [Applause]  i don't know if it really warranted  another technical knowing he's got one  already  but nevertheless it was unnecessary from  tress